so I told you yesterday that Fox news has
been really grasping at straws over the Trump
impeachment hearings. And I predict that that's
going to get even worse today because Lieutenant
Colonel
Alexander Veneman his testimony today, which
was the most specific and most devastating
to their narrative, but we'll have time for
that analysis. But in any case, even with
what's gone on so far, what went on last week
with the impeachment inquiry hearings, Fox
has really been grasping at straws to try
to defend the president's narrative, really
having no serious criticism other than there's
hearsay. And as we pointed out yesterday,
Oh, George Kent drank a medical amount of
water during the hearing. But something really
interesting happened on Fox news during the
impeachment inquiry hearing on Friday with
former Ukrainian ambassador Marie Evanovich.
Donald Trump was tweeting in real time, uh,
and started attacking the witness on Twitter
while she was testifying. Now, this is a form
of witness intimidation and a house intelligence
committee chairman Adam Schiff actually read
the tweets to Maria Bonovitch and had her
react in real time. And Bret Baier, the Fox
news host who, uh, was, uh, commenting on
the hearings off and on, and also tweeting
pointed out this is sort of a new impeachable
offense during an impeachment inquiry hearing
against Donald Trump.
He is taking actions which could be construed
as witness intimidation and thus new reasons
why the president should be impeached. Potentially
he's creating new reasons to impeach him during
the impeachment inquiry hearings. Bret Baier
tweeting and realtime quote, that was a turning
point in this hearing so far. She was already
a sympathetic witness and the president's
tweet ripping her allowed shift to pointed
out in realtime characterizing it as witness
tampering or intimidation. Adding an article
of impeachment in new, in real time. And Fox
had this guest, Chad [inaudible], who reflectively
and hilariously grasped at I guess the only
straw that he could muster up, which was to
say, well, you know, the constitution doesn't
specifically say anything about you aren't
supposed to intimidate witnesses. Watch, behold
the joke that this has become,
president Trump did that for them, so how
can Republicans try to clean that up? That
might be a challenge. Now, something else
that was said by Adam Schiff, the chair of
the intelligence committee, he indicated that
this might be an attempt to intimidate the
witness. Now when we look at the U S constitution
and we look at article two section four it
doesn't say anything about a witness intimidation.
You know, it talks about high crimes and misdemeanors,
bribery, which is a theme we've heard a lot
about here, but you could see potentially
that Democrats could use that moment to try
to tie that into an article of impeachment.
Well,
it must be fine then, right? Of course, you
can be impeached for high crimes and misdemeanors
and of course witness intimidation is there.
Quotes in the United States, the crime of
witness tampering in federal cases is defined
by statute at 18 USC subsection 1512 which
defines it as tampering with a witness, victim
or an informant. The punishment for such an
offense is up to 20 years. If physical force
was used, attempted or threatened, not looking
so good, all of a sudden. Now here's an opportunity
to clarify something else. You have a lot
of people on the right and some on the left,
but the ones on the right are are more into
defending Trump and they are saying, you know,
it's not really cleared which crimes count
as high crimes. High doesn't refer to the
crime. High refers to the criminal in the
sense that what makes something a high crime
is the perpetrator being someone highly placed
in government like the president or the vice
president and you.
It's a complete misunderstanding. When people
say, I need a list of what counts as a high
crime. No, it's crimes and misdemeanors that
become high by virtue of who is committing
them. And that's something that a lot of people
seem not to understand. Back to the coverage.
They're desperate. They're desperate to find
anything that they can to deflect and big
picture. It's failing. But at the same time
for the Fox news audience, it probably is
working and we'll see. You know, we were streaming
today's impeachment inquiry hearings. We'll
see what sort of graphics, Fox news put up
next to the witnesses today. Last week, we
know they were not only not charitable, they
actually perpetuated some of the conspiracies
being touted by president Donald Trump. Okay.